little nasa's x unofficial satan nike
containing human blood sells out under a
minute cnn says
rapper and singer little naz launches
his controversial shoes satan's shoes
featuring a bronze pentagram
an inverted cross and a drop of real
human blood
verified by nbc and they sold that
almost immediately the black and red
sneakers
part of a collaboration with between
little nasdaq and new york based art
collector
which ms mischief
mischief were made using nike air max
1997 though the sportswear brand has
distanced itself from the design in an
emailed statement to cnn nike said it
was not involved in creating the
modified sneakers
they were priced at a thousand eighteen
dollars there's a reason for the
reference to the bible passage
luke 10 18 that reads i saw satan fall
like a lightning like lightning from
heaven
each shoe's air bubble soul contains 60
cubic centimeters
2.03 fluid ounces of red ink and one
drop
of human blood uh a spokesperson for
them said the blood
has been provided by members of the art
collective adding
we love to sacrifice for our art yeah
interesting story i know you have
some strong feelings on this um
let me just come out and say uh this is
a publicity stunt completely
okay so little nausea might be the least
scariest person on the planet okay when
i think of
scary devil worshiper and let's talk
about who
actually you know filled that void for
for many many years yeah
marilyn manson ozzy osbourne uh black
sabbath alice cooper
heavy metal scary paint your face kiss
scary people
little nausea you know a fake cowboy
um not a tough guy whatsoever this is a
complete publicity stunt
he sold how many shoes 666
okay you know and respect to the devil
yep
um okay exactly
exactly and that's my point it's not
like he sold six million shoes
or six hundred thousand shoes or six
thousand shoes sold 666 shoes
some big time little nas ex fans came
out there probably kids
came out and spent all their money on it
on these shoes and they're like oh i got
little nonstack shoes
but he got what he wanted a publicity
stunt people
are basically talking about him look at
us talking about little nauseas i don't
know what song he's got out these days
obviously
his biggest well he was he had a new
song that came out that happened
with the shoes that has to do kind of
lines up with it
but i know you had a major problem with
why would nike allow this
why would nike they didn't exactly and
that's my point is the
this company mischief this marketing
company um
this brand where are you out with us tom
okay i i i i
think little nasa is actually the most
scary
person out there that could do something
like this because you wouldn't expect it
from him
and now he comes out here and says that
this is cool or whatever he's trying to
say i'm thoroughly disgusted by this
i i think there's ramifica i hope
mischief gets shut down
i mean i think i hope nike comes at them
as hard as they possibly can
and takes them out um i did a little
back you know a little research on this
group so the daniel greenberg he's the
head of the commerce for them
he did an interview with business
insider last year where he says um
we're in this weird place right now
where we're not really thinking like a
business we just do
and people buy our stuff and that's what
this whole thing feels like
hey quick publicity stunt let's do this
let's throw this out there you know pat
you made the point earlier
you know you can't drew brees almost got
canceled for saying that he's going to
stand for the national anthem because
it's important because his grandfather
served in world war ii and he had to
come out and do some whole dog and pony
show apology lil nash should be
cancelled you know and
it's so you want him to be cancer yes he
should be canceled for for promoting to
satan yes you should be cancelled here's
the other thing it's not because you're
a fan of cancer culture
no i'm not a fan of council culture i'm
i'm i'm at all
i hate cancer culture you want him but
if anybody should be canceled it's
little nas x for doing something like
this
i mean if you were to look at it
rationally and think why should someone
get canceled
doing something like this if you worship
the devil you should be canceled
i don't know i'm just saying we're
talking you just said it i'm talking
about lil nas x putting on a devil's
shoe
if someone should be canceled it should
be him by the way that song that he was
promoting in conjunction with this shoe
he gives the devil a lap dance okay so a
lot of people have come out and said
that they're gonna boycott lil nazex
forever
he tried to backtrack and do an apology
yesterday
so he creates a youtube video and before
he actually does the apology he
cuts to the clip of the song where he's
giving a devil a lap dance
so i got i got a major problem with him
i hope nike goes hard at mischief
and takes them out i mean if anybody
else makes a little mistake in this
world they got to pay for it why can't
they
let me say you're a father you're a
father so if i'm in your shoes
i probably would have stronger feelings
on this because i the last thing i would
want is dash who's a cool ass kid 12
years old
12 12 12 ortico
10 nine nine years old nine years old
at all listening to someone like this or
taking their advice okay but
you know what no one's canceling ozzy
osbourne no one was canceling marilyn
manson there was a lot of people
enraged by these people but listen if
you know anything about little nauseas
he is not a he's not scary he's not
tough
he runs around and he's singing that
what do you mean by that so if you're
like what do you mean scary and tough
okay so if you're like we're worried
he's going to come in the streets and be
no not like what do you mean
okay so i'm talking about how scary and
tough is about being buff and strong and
benching
i don't mean it i don't mean it like
that okay so how do you i mean i mean
when i think of
devil worshiper musicians yeah ozzy
osbourne as a kid i was scared as hell
about this guys guys eating
bats heads and doing stuff like that
yeah black sabbath alice cooper that was
scary like if you were a kid that's
scary
little nazex is wearing a rhinestone
cowboy outfit
talking about going down to old town
road it just doesn't
have the same oomph as the other
museu musician devil worshipers back in
the day
i think the only thing this a parent is
scared about is influence
that's my point with the kids there's
nothing about scary like you don't sit
there and say oh my gosh this guy looks
so scary giving the devil a lap dance
you're not scared by that it looks it
looks weird just doing that the whole
thing is now
um marketing side yes is is he got
everybody talking about him 24 7
yes is is all marketing on all publicity
good
i don't know i don't know if even a
marketing expert's gonna tell you all
publicity is good i don't know if this
is what's the famous line
you can say whatever you want about me
just spell my name right yeah that's
right so
so look here this is something where
uh i feel one phone call was made and
this is the one phone call that i think
was made
i don't know why i have a hunch i may be
wrong
forget i could be 100 wrong on this
totally fine with me
every company and organization has
somebody that behind closed doors
has so much influence nobody knows about
that if they make a phone call
you better listen to them i think
michael jordan may be calling and saying
what the hell are we doing
what the hell are we doing do you
realize i signed on with you
and look at the brand we've built can i
ask why this is happening
you don't think michael called one of
his guys and said can you go check on
these guys on what they're doing or
michael made the phone call himself
and then the lawsuit was you know
started immediately i don't know i just
think if michael's part of the
organization
do you think michael would endorse some
like this do you think michael would
support something like this do you think
michael is
aligned with some of these things here
not trying to get michael into
an issue that has nothing to do with
michael but at the same time to michael
it does
you know it's the same swoosh but you
know logo that's gonna be there and they
use the air max shoes there's 666 of
those to sell and they team up with
these guys so
i don't know i think there's serious
damage to the nike brand from this
because most people don't follow stories
like we do
i mean we'll see the headline we'll look
into it we'll follow it the next two
three days
most people are going to think nike was
behind this because there was a nike
shoe
and it was sold you're not automatically
going to think that somebody would be
stupid enough
to take a nike shoe and do this i cannot
believe the gall
of mischief to do this by the way the
founder of mischief was a former west
point military academy dropout
and he was has a history of doing goofy
projects he started an app that was
basically a tinder for airplanes which
is pretty funny if you think about it
you're on a plane on a long flight
you open up the at what you you go back
and chat up somebody and
wrote a milestone club opportunity right
there right so anyway but yeah nike if
they come at you with guns ablazing
you're done well let me ask you since
we're on the cancel culture you know the
the
the shoe that preceded this shoe
this this is the um this is the satan
shoe the shoe that preceded this shoe
the reason that they even had
the opposite the complete opposite was
the jesus shoe and rather than having a
drop of blood it had a drop of
holy water so that shoe did well so
are we saying and look i'm not buying
the shoe i don't really give two shits
about this story other than it's in the
news
are we allowed to cancel the devil's
shoe the satan shoe but not the jesus
this isn't a conversation about
canceling i don't think i i have
i hate cancer culture the whole thing i
was just simply making a point how easy
it is for some people to get canceled
for a tweet
or for saying something but you do
something like this and you're almost
applauded for it well it seems like
nike whether they were in the in the mix
or not they
come out and they've drawn a hard line
and they said
that quote unquote they were not
involved in any capacity and they have
no relationship
whatsoever with mischief or little
nausea
i think if you're very weird though that
they would even come out with the shoe
and now nike
has no relationship with them no no no
no they took that shoe and just modified
it and sold it as their own as the satan
shoe
nike had nothing to do with this and i
just think bottom line if you're a
christian you're a little bit offended
by this story
if you're not a christian probably want
to hit you as hard
i don't know i i i don't know if even a
person who's not a christian
is okay with this you know i i don't
think this is a christian issue i don't
i know a lot of people who are atheist
and agnostic who don't
you know worship the devil i know a lot
of people so i think it's it's not just
a christian thing i think it's a lot of
parenting
and parents are sitting around saying
okay here's a kid that watches you know
we all listen to the song you know when
you know the the song
it's one of our kids favorite songs to
listen to you know it's the number one
stream song of all time
most stream song ever so that same guy
comes out with this video that he came
up with if you see this video it's the
most weirdest video you'll see
it makes no sense and youtube allows
that video to stay on that's on youtube
i don't know i mean it's just
it's a pretty random video that's on
youtube so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody bye